el puerto vamos a hablar de fútbol de
fútbol español que está empañado por un
escándalo de racismo que afecta al
futbolista vinicius júnior sí Andrés el
brasileño denunciaba haber recibido este
domingo gritos y Arenas arengas de mono
en la derrota de su equipo el Real
Madrid en casa del Valencia bien eso es
que cargó contra la liga declaró que ya
han sido varias ofensas racistas de este
tipo de las que ha recibido en las
últimas horas el conjunto blanco
denunció este hecho ante la fiscalía por
presuntos delitos de odio el ente
acusador abrió de oficio una pesquisa
por este caso por su parte el presidente
de la liga Javier tebas quien discutió
con vinicios por redes sociales dijo el
brasileño que debería informarse y no
injuriar al campeonato son varios los
futbolistas que han enviado mensajes de
solidaridad a vinicios en medio de este
escándalo Incluso el presidente de la
FIFA ya ni fantino también se pronunció
solidaridad total con vinicios Leo
textualmente no hay lugar para el
racismo en el fútbol español o en
nuestra sociedad y la FIFA defiende a
todos los jugadores que se han
encontrado en esta en tal situación les
de Japón también se pronunció el
presidente de Brasil Lula da Silva al
término de la Cumbre del g7
no es justo que un chico que salió de la
pobreza que le ganó a la vida que se
está convirtiendo en uno de los mejores
jugadores del mundo ciertamente es el
mejor jugador del Real Madrid sea objeto
de abuso en cada estadio en el que juega